the idea was to come to the beaches and
to create a work of art on the beach and
to say goodbye to all the people who
left from these beaches a hundred years
ago
millions of men and women left Britain's
shores during the First World War and
many never returned score winning
director Danny Boyle has been tasked
with creating a nationwide commemoration
to mark the moment war finally ended and
we'll be inviting the public to gather
on Britain's beaches to remember we're
gonna create vast huge portrait on the
beach of a particular person on thirty
of the beaches it'll be a particular
person that's picked for reasons of
connection to a local community or in
this case in this Beach
it'll be Wilfred Owen who's a the
greatest poet of the First World War and
who left from this harbor for France
after his stunning success organizing
the opening ceremony of the Olympic
Games in London in 2012 it's hoped he
will again capture the mood of the
nation with this project which will
complement the more formal
commemorations being planned well it was
a great privilege to do it and an
incredible experience to do it and most
of that experience the incredible side
of it was to do with the volunteers this
is sort of it in the this is the reverse
of it were going to the communities to
their places and hoping that they turn
up again with the same spirit Danny was
asked to get involved with the project
by 14 to 18 now a program of arts
Commission's marking the first world war
centenary which is enlisted over 300
artists over the last five years his
will mark the final piece in a series
which has been seen by over 30 million
people in total its aim being to bring
the stories and individuals involved and
lost in the war to life when a thought
that originally it was about saying a
final goodbye I don't know whether it
should be the final goodbye that's
something for the country to decide
really it seems like a hundred years is
that enough is of we of we can we keep
doing that I sort of changed my mind
about that now I sort of feel we should
keep doing it Danny will now join a long
line of artists who have shaped
perceptions of the Great War over the
last hundred years reinventing the
traditional war memorial and helping
than they
remember Lucy cata Sky News